Hollywood runs on hype, from a project's earliest
conception to its world premiere and beyond,
the entire movie industry depends on getting
audiences as pumped as possible for their
blockbuster product.
In fact, there's an entire industry within
the industry, filled with people whose jobs
depend on getting the word out.
Unfortunately, the folks whose job it is to
market and hype up a film aren't always on
the same page as the people tasked with actually
making a movie.
Announcements are made, interviews are given,
and all of a sudden, the film just up and
disappears from the studio's release schedule.
It can happen for all sorts of surprising
reasons, but regardless, all we're left with
is the disappointment of knowing we'll never
get to see the movie we were promised.
Here's a look at some overhyped films that
quietly disappeared from the release schedule.
Dark Universe
The Dark Universe will probably go down in
Hollywood history as a prime example of the
high risk a studio runs of being embarrassed
by overhyped films.
In an attempt to mirror the Marvel Cinematic
Universe's interwoven narratives and massive
box office success, Universal Studios looked
to their own crossover-worthy characters,
classic monsters like Dracula, the Wolfman,
and more.
While it wouldn't be the first time Universal
had made crossover movies, the ideas behind
this new franchise seemed to borrow more from
superhero and action movies than the gothic
influences of their early 1900s forebears.
Universal even invested in a special "Dark
Universe" logo to introduce films that would
take place in this universe.
So...
"What happened?"
Unfortunately, despite all-star casting like
Tom Cruise in The Mummy and Johnny Depp as
the the Invisible Man, the Dark Universe was
quickly derailed when The Mummy bombed at
the box office.
Bride of Frankenstein, which was rumored to
star Angelina Jolie in the title role, was
quickly taken off of Universal's schedule,
and, despite a massive launch announcement
with a Photoshopped lineup of the stars, the
creatives behind the would-be franchise moved
on to other projects.
It looks like the real dark universe was ours,
all along.
Divergent: Ascendant
The Divergent adaptations seemed like a sure
thing.
Based on the hit Young Adult novels by Veronica
Roth, the dystopian action series seemed like
the natural heir to the Hunger Games hysteria
that dominated the box office.
Unfortunately, while the first two films managed
to earn a respectable return on investment,
they weren't quite as bankable as the studio
might've hoped.
Even so, Lionsgate went forward with splitting
the final film into two, like Harry Potter,
Twilight, and The Hunger Games before it,
and that decision turned out to be a huge
mistake.
Allegiant was only loosely based on the book
version of the same name, and not only were
the reviews for the film scathing, but fans
failed to turn up at the ticket booth as well.
As a result, the would-be final film, Ascendant,
fell apart at the seams by losing its director
and cast, and then being shunted off to the
television circuit, where it's remained in
production limbo.
World War Z 2
Based on the gripping bestseller by Max Brooks,
World War Z came loaded with a passionate
fan-base, including some of Hollywood's most
prestigious actors.
After a bidding war against Leonardo DiCaprio's
production group Appian Way, Brad Pitt's company
Plan B optioned and produced the film adaptation
of the apocalyptic zombie thriller.
Unfortunately, things start going downhill
from there as the film became an entirely
different kind of disaster movie.
After the initial filming process was complete,
the flick went through a massive reshoot process
that basically replaced the film's entire
third act and made it unrecognizable to readers
of Brooks' version.
Although it still went on to score a solid
half-billion dollars at the box office, the
film's ballooned production costs ate into
those profits.
A sequel was still announced by Paramount
Pictures, due to the bounty of book material
left to bring to the big screen.
"We have so many ideas and so much information
that we think we've got a lot of stuff to
mine from."
However, the film's release date has continued
to be bumped back again and again to the point
that it seems like director David Fincher
might never get a chance to resurrect this
franchise.
Terminator Genisys 2
The first Terminator: Genisys left a lot to
be desired.
For instance, the movie was straight up incomplete
and basically relied on the eventual sequel
to complete the narrative.
Unfortunately, planning for a sequel can backfire
if the released movie underperforms, and that's
exactly what happened with Genisys.
The film did have some serious star power
with Emilia Clarke and the return of Arnold
Schwarzenegger, who made good on that promise
…
"I'll be back."
(Please Arnold, don't.)
However, the movie underperformed in the US
and fell short of its production budget by
about $60 million.
What was meant to be the birth of a new trilogy
turned out to be a non-starter, and the second
installment was removed from Paramount's upcoming
releases, paving the way for yet another adjustment
of franchise continuity with a sequel that
would ignore everything after Judgement Day.
Fantastic Four 2
Years before anyone seriously believed Marvel
Comics could spin off anything approaching
a cinematic universe, the venerable publisher
fell on hard financial times and ended up
selling off the film rights to some of their
most popular characters.
Spider-Man landed at Sony and the Fantastic
Four and X-Men landed at Fox, and without
access to those heroes, the fledgling Marvel
Studios turned to characters like Iron Man,
Captain America, and Thor, which were at the
time properties that had never achieved quite
as much mainstream popularity.
Of course, this all ended up working out pretty
well for Marvel, and for Fox and Sony, both
of whom found themselves sitting on adaptation
options that had never been more valuable.
As a result, Spidey and the Fantastic Four
have both spawned multiple franchises, but
while Sony has managed to hit box office paydirt
with its Spider-Man movies on more than one
occasion, the Fantastic Four films have had
a rougher go of it.
Fox's first pass at the franchise made money,
but the reviews were less than kind, prompting
a reboot in 2015, and that attempt fared even
worse than its predecessors, earning godawful
reviews and the worst grosses of any theatrical
release in the series.
Still, there's no benefit to holding film
rights you can't use, so Fox executives consistently
reiterated that a sequel was definitely happening,
regardless of what happened with the first
film.
Considering that the latest release date promised
a June 2017 arrival, we can pretty safely
assume that the sequel won't be happening.
The Disney-Fox merger deal might mean that
Marvel's First Family will get another shot
at a movie release sometime, although it likely
won't be anytime soon, and it won't be a follow-up
to any past Fantastic Four film...which is
probably just as well.
Sinister Six
Sony didn't just own the rights to Spider-Man;
the studio also laid claim to an assortment
of other characters related to everyone's
favorite friendly neighborhood web-slinger.
In order to compete with Marvel's growing
domination of the superhero genre, Sony announced
plans in 2014 to make a Sinister Six movie,
to be directed by Drew Goddard.
The film's conceit was fairly ambitious, bringing
together six of Spidey's most famous villains
together as the titular supervillain team.
Promotional materials were even created to
build fan fervor following the release of
The Amazing Spider-Man 2.
Sadly, while everyone involved seemed invested
in making Sinister Six a reality, the Amazing
Spider-sequel underperformed, paving the way
for a deal between Marvel and Sony that was
struck just in time to reboot the character
again with Tom Holland in the role, and have
Spidey make his Marvel Cinematic Universe
debut alongside Captain America and Iron Man
in Captain America: Civil War.
It led to all sorts of Spider-Man goodness,
but the collateral damage of the deal included
Goddard's Sinister Six.
Sony hasn't given up on Spider-spinoffs, and
although subsequent plans to continue building
out the character's shared universe have hit
some snags of their own, fans can still look
forward to a big-screen solo outing for at
least one of Spider-Man's most popular foes.
Uncharted
When it comes to experiences that feel like
watching an Indiana Jones movie, you're mostly
limited to getting a doctorate in archeology
or going on the Indiana Jones ride at Disneyland.
Still, the Uncharted video game series manages
to scratch the particular itch of watching
a handsome and dashing adventurer run around
giant monuments while flirting with pretty
girls and almost getting killed by amoral
thieves.
The series follows Nathan Drake as an artifact
hunter whose adventures in picturesque locations
and grand action set pieces seemed absolutely
made for the big screen.
While movie adaptations of video games tend
to be poorly received, adapting Uncharted
seemed like a perfect continuation of the
pulpy adventure movies that Indiana Jones
had traded in.
Unfortunately, the movie ran through a series
of difficult turnovers as director after director
left the project.
Joe Carnahan was tapped to write the script
in 2016, but the Uncharted movie was removed
from Sony's upcoming release list only a few
months later.
Still, fans don't need to lose hope completely;
a since-deleted Instagram post by Tom Holland
seemed to imply that he would be starring
in the long-awaited movie.
Much like any archaeologist, fans will just
have to wait and see if what comes out of
the ground is treasure...or trash.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!